all right McCoy's departure from Tampa
is the basis for today's draft which
other veterans are most in danger of
being cut or more accurately having a
mutual parting of ways with their
current team Chris go ahead Cortes oh he
call him tails today yeah I know
yesterday yeah I got was right yesterday
I go tails yeah yep let's go tails well
you were right yesterday but I
dominating the draft people actually
felt bad for you yesterday whatever
right go ahead okay here we go
Roger Staubach yeah I liked my list
yesterday I mean my list I was a lot
richer than your list yeah you got you
got memorable jail time good job on that
one
okay all right there's a lot to pick
pick from here but I think the first guy
that I look at to be maybe a cap
casualty or something along training
camps is Josh Norman that's the first
guy I'm gonna throw out there okay Josh
Norman hey we've heard he was put on
notice by the Washington Redskins in the
offseason a little bit Jay Gruden said
hey for 15 million dollars a year we
need more we need him to dominate we
need him to play better so we heard
those type of comments now the big thing
is they're gonna need for these
situations to arise you need guys that
are on the roster to kind of rise up to
give the coaches the confidence to make
a move like this but I think Josh Norman
was some of the antics we've heard you
know last offseason our last season when
Jay Gruden had to rip the earphones off
of them during halftime and he got
benched in the second half of the New
Orleans game you know so I think there's
little things there to look at to go
okay this relationship isn't just
absolutely perfect and you know all
flowers and roses and with that type of
money yeah I you know Josh Norman is not
the best corner in football and
certainly not the best man-to-man cover
for in football I could see it happening
well and also last week there was the
comment from Fred smooth to NBC Sports
Washington that they should cut Josh
Norman you just wonder when something
like that happens
who's he hearing that from yeah kind of
a trial balloon and and Josh Norman has
I think been hampered by the fact that
the cornerback market hasn't grown in
recent years so his contract is still 15
million a year right yeah and it's like
this is entering year
or maybe this is a guy that that we
should move on from and they they're not
a team that's in desperate need of calf
space but when you consider all the
money that is being paid to Alec Smith
who won't be playing this year any
dollars you can legitimately save you
have to look into doing that right
speaking of a team that could use saving
some dollars and and and has more cap
issues than you would think they would
the Pittsburgh Steelers a name that's
been hovering around and you never know
when this is gonna happen it happened to
Joe Hayden in Cleveland late in the
offseason a few years ago before he
signed with the Steelers and I think Joe
Hayden is a real possibility at some
point and he could get the mid August
they come to him and they say we'd like
to keep you around but you know Justin
Lane the rookies looking pretty good so
you know maybe you'd have less playing
time and if we keep you around we can't
afford to pay you 10 million dollar
salary this year maybe we pay you five
and maybe he says yes because you don't
know a lot of their options I mean teams
do that all the time where they wait
until the market is dried up all the
seats are taken with other depth charts
and what's a guy gonna do what's he
gonna say you you take the release at
that point and you may not get anything
close to what the team is offering on a
reduced salary so Joe Hayden is a guy
I'm keeping an eye on it will not
surprise me if he is a quote-unquote
surprise cut by the Steelers before week
one yeah I hear ya I think he was
certainly one of the guys on my radar
for this discussion yeah I mean the best
years of Joe Hayden career are over he
certainly seemed to like playing in
Pittsburgh ever since he's had the the
scenery change getting out of Cleveland
seems happy there and seems to found a
niche for himself to where yeah that
could be one of those things where he
might agree to take a little less money
to stay in a dress yeah Robert Jerome
Bettis every year for like three
straight years took less and less and
less and less because he wanted to stay
in Pittsburgh right and what's your
alternative so that may be what they do
to Joe Hayden yeah no doubt about that
so that's not a bad one with you I'm not
gonna argue I think there might have
been better ones out there though that's
all I'll say forgive me you're up the
hill Sanders Denver Broncos that's one
I'm gonna look at right there okay you
know 32 years in age okay first of all
you're nine of your NFL career he's on
the hook for you know I'm he's going to
make somewhere over eight million
dollars this year coming off an Achilles
tear head there's a cap hit of ten
million dollars you know I just look at
that and go ooh
okay that type of injury at that
position there was little Inklings
during the offseason about maybe Emanuel
Sanders being asked to take a pay cut
aye sir it didn't seem like into social
media of reactions that he would be in
favor of that but again one of those
situations where there's some young
receivers in Denver DeSean Hamilton
Courtland Sutton guys that have kind of
shown that they have the potential to be
something if another guy can kind of
jump up into the fray at the wide
receiver position to where again the
Broncos can trust them and I don't know
who that guy would be I think that might
be one where they might look at and go I
don't know if I want to have ten million
dollars on the salary cap count on
Emanuel Sanders a guy who might not be
able to give us a whole lot this year
here's why I disagree with you yeah
because they had an opportunity to move
on from Emanuel Sanders before the 12th
of March and they picked up his option
for 2019 that guarantees one and a half
million dollars now look one and a half
million right isn't so much that you
can't decide in August this guy doesn't
have it anymore or that you can't go to
him August when there are no empty spots
on other depth charts at the top where
you would walk in as a starter and we
know how difficult it is for a receiver
to jump onto a new team in August
September and get up to speed maybe
Denver is plotting to get that
one-and-a-half million back and then
some same ideas with Joe Hayden go to
him late in the process and say look
what we just don't think the 10 million
dollars reflects your current value and
we think that other teams would agree
with us so why don't you just take six
or five or whatever and we'll stay
together but they've already given him a
guarantee yeah now if there's offset
language look he goes somewhere else
they caught him and he still makes his 1
and a half million so it could still
happen but they had a window to do it
and they chose to to kick the can and I
was a little surprised they did that if
they are seriously thinking about moving
on from it so but again yeah somebody
else somebody else would pay him one and
a half million and they won't owe him
anything at the end of the day anyway
all right you know yeah this was too
easy well I'm gonna go a little Shawn
McCoy you know because Leroy the the
news hound owned by my Internet son PFT
commoner threw it out
there a couple of weeks ago but LeSean
McCoy could be released by the bills as
soon as today now that was shot down to
which Leroy pointed out well as soon as
today means it could happen at any point
at some point it will happen but six
point seven or six point 1 million they
drafted a running back they they have
Frank Gore and and there's just been
this sense that the bills are just kind
of looking for the right opportunity to
move on from LeSean McCoy it's never
felt like a comfortable relationship but
they've kept him because he's good he's
getting to the point in his career where
maybe the skills don't justify six
million dollars I could see him making a
beeline back to Philadelphia if he gets
an opportunity although they have a
crowded house at tailback now I think he
would still play but if they can't find
a suitor in trade if they would even try
to do that and there are some rumors out
there that they are looking for a trade
partner maybe they do cut LeSean McCoy
and they go with the rookie and they go
with Frank Gore yeah I certainly I could
see that definitely I'm in LeSean McCoy
we've seen him get injured a little bit
over the last two years you know so you
worry about that especially at the
running back position having to deal
with that they got TJ Yeldon right and
free agency this year so they got some
depth at the position drafted Devin
Singletary out of Florida Atlantic you
know in this past draft so there's other
guys there certainly yeah I I guess what
I look at is go man are you gonna you're
gonna let go of allah sean mccoy and
have a frank gore who's a little bit
older take over you know the the heavy
duty or the heavy lifting their or maybe
they do just go with TJ Yeldon but McCoy
I still think has some specialness about
his movement okay round three I'm gonna
go down to Atlanta for this one you know
maybe not as a famous of a football
player some of the guys we've mentioned
already but still a really good football
player and that's Mohamed Sanu
wide receiver for the Atlanta Falcons
what I've heard you know little rumors
here and there throughout the offseason
that you know that Atlanta might be
shopping on Mohamed Sanu so that of
course brings me it brings my attention
to this but they did draft Calvin Ridley
last year in the first round out of
Alabama he had a pretty damn good rookie
year of course Julio Jones is still
there and wanting more money and Mohamed
Sanu counting seven point six million
dollars against the cap yeah I could see
that as being a guy that towards the end
of training camp again a lot
like a lot of these cases here if
somebody kind of rises to the top where
the organization feels comfortable a guy
like Mohamed Sanu could certainly be the
casualty from that effect because of the
point he's out in his career and the
amount of money he's making I remember
new offensive coordinator this year in
Dirk cutter and if it just if it doesn't
click and cutter used to be the
offensive coordinator had been the coach
of the Buccaneers for several seasons
and maybe maybe it is time to move on
and it's always that sliding scale
because you get those rookies who step
up and they are making so much less than
the established veteran players and that
that's that's got to create so much
angst every year when the draft rolls
around for the veteran players because
they get a young guy who's healthy who's
cheap yeah and this rookie wage skill
has made it so much easier for teams to
move on from veteran players or squeezed
veteran players to take less money and
meanwhile I get a lot of teams that
aren't spending anywhere close to the
total limit under the salary cap all
right I'm gonna I'm gonna I don't know
if this violates the rules of the draft
or not I don't care I'm going to combine
two guys cuz they play the same position
in Washington the Washington veteran
tight ends Jordan Reed and Vernon Davis
I think both are in jeopardy of being
cut Reid's got a seven point six million
dollar salary he always seems to be
injured
Davis has four point seven five million
dollars on the books it could be they
offer a reduced package to both guys and
whoever says yes first gets to stay and
the other guy is gone Chris well gosh
here you are I mean we've had two
segments today and you can't stay within
the guidelines of the damn segments okay
I mean we had word association with Kyle
Emery and Kliff Kingsbury I've still yet
to get your word okay you said you've
got work for you and here we are now
picking two players in the third round
okay I can see maybe the Vernon Davis
one I'm not gonna say the Jordan Reed
one cuz I just think he's still such a
special player you're you're right about
that we know I know the injury concerns
are very real there but it is a special
talent that he has and I just think that
it's rare in the NFL to wear the
Redskins aren't gonna let him go or try
to mess that up but the injury things a
real issue but I guess I won the draft
that's pretty much over since you broke
the
the bylaws champion 50-54 catches for
558 yards and two touchdowns last year
look I know tight end is not you know
don't expect the same production as a
receiver but that's that's not seven
point six million dollars in production
they had 211 yards a year before that
because he missed ten games due to
injury he's never appeared in all 16
games the most he ever appeared in was
2015 with 14 games he's never started
more than eight games in a season all
right we had Oh Jay Simpson in
yesterday's draft and we've mentioned
you did the draft because it's the most
memorable
post-playing career of anyone in the
foa's you have a higher tor the scouting
here.we I don't get I don't get member
with prior histories so I don't drop
those kind of guys on my team
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports